If you upload this skill onto Claude,
it'll do an in-depth backlink
opportunity report for any website. If
you want to get access to this Claude
skill, just comment backlink below and I
will send it over to you. As you can see
here, here's the full Claude skill. It's
very, very in-depth and essentially goes
out and does in-depth research on live,
up-to-date data to give you a backlink
opportunity plan for your website to
increase your domain authority. So, we
can see here, we've already went ahead
and ran this on a site that does tours
in Niagara Falls. We can see the full
report that's been generated from
Claude. There's 24 opportunities, eight
quick wins, 13 that are high value, two
that are volume plays, one is a
long-term approach, and four link bait
ideas. We also get a competitor backlink
analysis, and ideally this should give
you the domain rating, the referring
domains, and the top linking domains.
So, we just have to optimize the prompt
so it ensures it does live web research
or uses Google Chrome to actually go out
on Ahrefs or SimilarWeb and do some
backlink analysis. Next, we get the
prioritized backlink opportunities. So,
based upon this website, here are some
of the quick wins
that are in order of importance. So,
number one is actually going out
and improving our Google My Business.
So, fully optimize Google My Business,
include all fields, images, so on and so
forth. Next, it's telling us to add our
listing on TripAdvisor, Yelp,
Viator.com, GetYourGuide, Travels
Ride.com, Travel Tour, TouristEar, and
so on and so forth. So, of course, this
is going to change based upon your
specific niche. Because this is in the
travel niche, these are the guest um
these are the directories and the guest
post opportunities in which we're
getting. So, we see here on this
specific website, we have the ability to
do guest posts. So, right here, we
actually get the link for the guest post
link um opportunity. So, quick win,
submit a 1,200 article on and it gives
us an actual topic here
that we can contribute over to this
website. So, we get a mixture of
directory listing, resource pages, and
guest post opportunities in which we can
go after. And also, skyscraper target,
link insertion, so on and so forth. So,
just from this report here, we get a lot
of things that we can do that actually
moves the needle if we would like to go
ahead and improve our DR. We also get a
30, 60, and a 90-day roadmap and link
bait content strategy. So, if you
actually wanted to go ahead and write
your article, I would definitely,
definitely recommend using Word Rocket.
Now, there's two main ways in which you
can do so. We can simply go over to Word
Rocket, paste in the article
that
the report gave us to write about. So,
let's say if we wanted to write the
article about the guest post. So,
Niagara Falls, Canada pitch, your full
complete itinerary, what no one tells
you.
Let's say if we wanted to write this
article, I could simply go ahead, put
this into Word Rocket, and I've already
went ahead and I've already added in
this
website or brand onto
um onto Word Rocket. So, I can simply
enter in the topic. I like to toggle
toggle on web research, and I've entered
in
the brand settings, and I've also
uploaded the logo, so the logo will be
integrated into the actual image. Or,
what I can do is I can actually go back
over to Claude,
and you need to ensure that the Word
Rocket MCP is connected. So, if I head
over to settings, and if I head over to
connectors,
and I'm going to ensure my Word Rocket
AI connection is connected. If you
wanted to connect a new connector, just
go to browse connectors, I believe
or customize, sorry, customize
add a new connector. So, add a custom
connector, Word Rocket, and you enter in
the
URL
the URL wordrocketapi.com.
Right? So, once you enter that in and
you have access to the agency plan,
you'll be able to use Word Rocket right
within Claude. So, let's go and show you
how that would work. So, going back over
to the actual um backlink report that we
got back, I can tell it to
write an article on the topic of Niagara
Falls tourism stats. So, this is the
link bait article example that we got
from the from the actual report. Right?
So, I'm going to tell it to use the Word
Rocket connector, use my brand voice,
use my site map, include three images
and live web search mode, and write on
the article,
and I give it the topic. So, I'm just
going to tell it to use the Word Rocket
MCP. So, right within our backlink audit
report, we can then invoke the Word
Rocket MCP. So, this again opens up a
whole bunch of opportunities because we
don't have to go actually back into Word
Rocket. We can do everything right
within Claude. Super, super powerful. If
you want to get access to the Claude MCP
with Word Rocket, just head over to
app.wordrocket.ai and sign up for an
agency plan. So, next, we have some
outreach email templates. So, we
actually have templates in which we can
use to outreach over
to websites for guest posts, for link
insertion, or for resource page
addition. Right? So, we all we don't
have to do any of the heavy lifting. All
of the heavy lifting is done for us. We
just have to go through our action plan
and, you know, use the information
that's given. So, as you can see, super,
super simple and easy to follow, but
actionable. It will actually help you to
improve your domain authority. So, going
back over to the first article on which
we wrote, which is about Niagara Falls,
Canada,
um the pitch. So, we can see the full
article here, right? What no one tells
you. So, you can see that this actually
has our brand logo integrated into the
image, which is one of our latest
additions from Word Rocket. We get our
quick answer, we get our last updated
date, we get our key insights, we get
another beautiful, beautiful image, and
we get a full article here that we can
use with internal linking, beautiful,
beautiful images that are branded, and
we get our references that are included.
So, all of our content can be written
using Word Rocket, and then we can use
it for whatever use case we like. If
it's a guest post, a link insertion,
link bait article,
um whatever it may be. And again, as I
mentioned to you, you can write your
articles directly into
Claude using the Word Rocket MCP
integration. So, I hope that you guys
enjoyed today's video. If you did, let
it be known by giving us a big thumbs
up, and I'll see you in the next one.
Take care.